Hi everyone.
My name is Barbara Ferrari and I am the
financial director at students in
support of free speech at York
University.
I'll keep all the insurance for tonight
short cause we really don't have any
time.
Um,
if you're ever traveling downtown on a
Tuesday night around seven o'clock and
you pass by the Isabelle Theater,
the Isabel Bader theater,
you'll see hundreds of people,
about 500 people lined up outside.
And you'll ask yourself,
why are there these older people,
younger people,
why is everyone just outside waiting in
a line?
And it's confusing.
You think maybe there's a celebrity
there.
You know,
it turns out it's professor Peterson
discussing the psychological
significance of the biblical stories.
Hundreds
[inaudible]
hundreds and hundreds of people sold out
crowds every single week.
And I often ask myself,
what is it about Professor Peterson that
just attract such a large audience?
And for me personally,
it's how genuine he is when he speaks.
Many times you'll see them get on stage
and be emotional and you don't really
get that from many speakers.
Also the professors command of the
English language is,
it's so eloquent and yet so simple to
understand which use.
It's really unfound nowadays.
It's really amazing to have professor
Peterson here cause he was the initial
inspiration behind students and support
a free speech.
[inaudible]
on that note,
it is my pleasure to introduce professor
Jordan Peterson.
[inaudible].
I'm going to talk to you a bit briefly
about why postmodernism is wrong.
And I actually mean technically wrong,
apart from ethically wrong and morally
wrong and intellectually and emotionally
rolling practically wrong.
But I'll give the devil his due to begin
with because they are actually wrestling
with quite a difficult problem.
And the founders of postmodernism,
we're by no means I'm unintelligent
individuals and they actually put their
finger on quite an important problem.
The important problem that they put
their finger on was the fact that any
set of phenomena has a near infinite
number of potential interpretations.
And that actually happens to be the
case.
Uh,
that that fact,
let's say,
was discovered simultaneously in a
number of different disciplines.
Um,
one of the most surprising it was
artificial intelligence and the
artificial intelligence people ran into
that conundrum when they learned that it
was much more difficult to make a
machine that could perceive the world
that had originally been supposed,
you know,
we're supposed to have autonomous robots
and or,
and,
and functional artificial intelligence
backed by the late sixties.
And of course that didn't happen.
And part of the reason for that was that
the artificial intelligence researchers,
when they were starting to instantiate
perception into their machines,
learned that charting your course in the
world might be a trivial problem in
comparison to determining how to
perceive the world.
And the reason for that is that there's
a very large number of ways to perceive
the world.
And the postmodernist actually caught
onto this and one of the claims they
made was that while there's a near
infinite number of ways to interpret any
given text,
and that actually also happens to be the
case.
And then they said,
well,
since there's a near infinite number of
ways to interpret any texts,
how do you know that any given
interpretation should,
should take precedence over any other
interpretation,
which is also a perfectly reasonable
issue.
Um,
they went off the rails very rapidly
after putting forward that set of
propositions.
And that's partly why they also kept
their alliance with Marxism.
Because the problem with postmodernism
fundamentally is that if you,
um,
agree with the proposition that all
interpretations of all phenomena are of
equal value or lack of value,
then you can't act in the world.
And the problem with that is that if
you're a human being,
you have to act in the world because
otherwise you,
you,
you suffer miserably and then you die.
And that seems to be,
that seems to be an unacceptable outcome
for most people.
So the issue with postmodernism isn't so
much the,
the erroneous claim that there are very
large number of interpretations for any
given phenomena,
including the meaning of a text.
The error in postmodernism is the
failure to recognize that there are a
finite number of credible
interpretations of phenomena.
And also a refusal to engage with the
intellectual problem that determining
what that finite set might actually
consist of.
And I will,
I'll just give you a very brief overview
of how it is that we happen to solve
this problem as human beings.
And we do it partly biologically because
we inhabit a biological framework that's
been developed over the course of about
3.5 million years.
That severely constrains the manner in
which we interpret the world.
And it constrains it such that we tend
to only manifests,
spontaneously manifest interpretations
of the world that don't result in undue
suffering and our demise.
And there's plenty of ways to be stupid
enough to parish.
enough to suffer without meaning.
But there aren't very many ways to live
properly and carefully for a long period
of time in a manner that doesn't also
similar caneously do harm to other
people.
And so that's the second set of
constraints is that you have biological
constraints on your perception.
Then they're built in as a consequence
of a Darwinian process.
And the second part is that you're
forced to interact with yourself now in
this week,
next week and the week after and the
month after and the year after.
So you have to conduct yourself in a way
that doesn't interfere with your future
life as you're living now.
And simultaneously you have to conduct
yourself in a way that makes all the
other people around you want to
cooperate with you and compete with you
and maintain their relationship with you
and do that today and next week and next
month,
the next year and so on into the future.
So there are sip,
although there are very large number of
interpretations of the world,
there are unbelievably severe
constraints on the number of functional
interpretations there are in the world.
And one of the things that the
humanities was supposed to be educating
people with regards towards
understanding was what the universe of
those finite functional interpretations
might be.
And that's been more or less abandoned
by the universities under the guise of
postmodernism.
Um,
the,
the fact that the postmodernist is dare
to be Marxist is also something that I
find,
I would say not so much intellectually
reprehensible,
as morally repugnant.
And one of the things that,
one of the things that the
postmodernists postmodern,
Neo Marxists continually claim is that
they have nothing but compassion for the
downtrodden.
And I would say that anybody with more
than a cursory knowledge of 20th century
history who dares to claim
simultaneously that they have compassion
for the downtrodden and that they're
marxists are revealing either their
ignorance of history that is so
astounding that it's actually a form of
miracle or a kind of
aura kind of malevolence that's so
reprehensible that it's almost
unspeakable because we already ran the
equity experiment over the course of the
20th century and we already know what
the,
the Marxist doctrines have done for all
press people all around the world.
And the answer that mostly was in
prison,
in slave imprisoned them,
enslaved them,
work them to death or execute them.
And as far as I can tell,
that's not precisely commensurate with
any message of compassion.
And so I don't think that the postmodern
neo Marxist have a leg to stand on
ethically or intellectually or
emotionally or,
and I think that they should be gone
after as hard as possible from an
intellectual perspective and informed
intellectual perspective.
And this is fundamentally a war of
ideas.
And that's the,
that's the level of analysis that it
should be thought upon.
And not only is it a war of ideas,
I think it's one that can be one because
I think that the,
especially the French intellectual
postmodernists or a pack of,
um,
what would you call them?
Um,
well we could start with charlatans.
That's a good one.
So pseudo intellectual would be good.
Resentful would be another.
And then I would also consider them
highly,
they're highly deceptive in their
intellectual strategies because almost
all of them were Marxists student
intellectuals.
And they knew by the time the Gulag
archipelago came out.
And even before that,
that the,
the,
the nightmares of the Soviet Union and
Maoist China were of such magnitude that
they had completely invalidated any
claim to ethical justification that the
fundamental Marxist doctrines had ever
managed to manage,
to mount accessed.
And so it's an,
it's a no go zone as far as I'm
concerned.
Intellectually the game's over.
We've already figured out that there are
finite constraints on interpretation and
we also understand why those exist and
how they evolved in from,
from the perspective of of political
argumentation.
There's absolutely no excuse whatsoever
in the 21st century to put forth Marxist
doctrines as if they're the,
the bomb that's needed by the compassion
to then buy the bomb that's administered
by the Compassionate to the downtrodden.
Sorry,
tried that.
Didn't work.
We got 100 million corpses to prove it.
And that's plenty for me.
And if it's not enough for you,
well then you should do some serious
thinking either about your historical
knowledge or about your moral character.
So that's the first.
Thanks.
Okay,
so the next thing is what to do about
it.
And I think I thought about a lot of
things,
but what might be done about it apart
from just talking about it,
which seems to be reasonably effective,
but um,
I thought for awhile that it would be
useful for the,
for the,
for,
for the political systems,
people who are running the political
systems to consider doing something like
cutting the funding of universities by
25% and letting them fight over the
remains and hopefully what that would
mean,
hopefully that would mean that the
pseudo disciplines such as women's
studies,
which never had a methodology to
methodology that was credible to begin
with.
And I would put in the same
classification all the ethnic and racial
studies groups that are popping up on
campuses like mad under the guise of,
of,
of true disciplines,
which the,
not in any sense of the imagination,
but also or any sets of the word,
but also increasingly the social
sciences and the general humanities that
have been corrupted quite terribly by
the postmodern doctrines.
I thought,
well maybe it would be good to see if
the funding could be cut for them
because,
because there's no reason that the
public at large should be funding a
fifth column whose aim is to disrupt the
fundamental structures of Western
civilization with tax money that's
devoted to supporting people while
they're doing it.
No,
I'd
like to think about that.
It'd be nice if that was a paranoid
delusion and of course when I first
started talking about this,
the first thing that people thought and
quite rightly was who the hell is this
crazy professor and how many things
might there be wrong with him?
Which is exactly,
which is exactly what you should think
when someone stands up and says,
Hey,
you know this system that you guys all
think is going really well and that's
been going wrong well for decades,
there's something seriously rotten about
it that you should be paying attention
to.
The first thing you should think of is,
well,
what makes you think you're not insane?
And because that is the right that is
the right answer under those
circumstances.
But it turned out,
at least as far as I can tell,
that I'm not actually,
and that the things that,
and if the things that I were pointing
out,
we're actually factual and what happened
in Canada at least,
and I would say to some degree around
the world,
was that as journalists who actually
happened to be concerned about free
speech,
generally speaking,
started to look into the claims that I
was making about such things as the
legislative policies surrounding bill c
16 they realized that I was actually
just reading what was written on the
page and understanding it instead of
trying to blow something out of
proportion,
which I had absolutely no motivation
whatsoever to do.
But then,
you know,
I thought,
um,
no,
you can't have political interference
with the universities because what
happens is that,
you know,
you think what happens is that if you
arm the politicians so that they can
start telling the universities what they
can and cannot teach,
even with regards to funding is then
that goes seriously sideways very
rapidly.
And you don't end up with a result that
you wanted.
Do you end up with some other result?
Because you know how it is when you
allow one organization to interfere with
the autonomous function of another is
that it isn't the people that you want
to do with the regulating that end up
doing the regulating and the things that
you end up getting regulated aren't the
things that you want to stop.
So that's not a good idea.
So I think I have a better idea and I
think better idea is that the postmodern
or should be starved at their source.
And,
and I,
I don't use that terminology lightly.
I think that what needs to happen is
that freshmen and second year university
students and,
and students coming into university from
high school and need to be educated
about the postmodern cult and they need
to be encouraged to not take the
courses,
to just drop the courses,
to just stay the hell away from them.
And the humanities enrollments have been
declining precipitously since the 1960s
and a big part of that is that,
you know,
why in the world would you go as a half
confused high school student into
university and get whatever shreds of,
of culture that you're still clinging to
to keep your poor head above water in
the sea of chaos that threatens to
surround you,
taken away by your professors.
So you're stripped bare of anything but
some vague sense that maybe you're a
horrible racist unconsciously in some
manner that you can't detect and then be
left with nothing that,
that for your,
for your hundred thousand dollar
investment in your bloody student loan.
So people are smart enough maybe not to
continue to enroll in that sort of thing
over time.
And the humanities have been being
decimated since the 1960s as a
consequence.
But it's time for that process to
accelerate.
And so here's something cool that
happened this week,
I think.
Um,
I decided a couple of weeks ago to make
a postmodern lexicon and I started
analyzing word use in,
I was gathering abstracts from this
twitter site called new real peer
review,
which is something that the
postmodernists really hate
because of course what new real peer
reviewed does this take actual published
abstracts from postmodern humanities
journals,
which by the way have a zero citation
rate of 80% and merely and merely
republish them and the abstracts are so
reprehensible and so incoherent and so
cult like an ideologically addled that
the people who wrote them get irritated
when other people read them.
I know which is,
which is a good,
because the original,
the real peer review,
which was the first one was shut down by
people who are irritated that the people
who ran the twitter site had the
unmitigated gall to actually publicize
writing that was written to be
publicized.
It was like the only situation I've ever
seen were authors were actually
embarrassed that someone did what they
could to publicize what they'd written.
Anyways,
new real peer review picked up where
they stopped and has been publishing
abstracts like mad from these crazy
postmodern journals.
Uh,
what's your journal is only a name.
And so I started to pull out key key
words were,
I'll tell you a little bit about that
game in a minute.
Um,
I started to pull out key words that
were emblematic of the,
let's call it the postmodern cult.
And then I thought,
I generated questionnaire that that
parents of university students and,
and late stage high school students and
freshman in university and maybe second
year students could use as a guideline
so they could look at the course
descriptions and checkoff word frequency
from the postmodern list and decide that
if the course was part of the postmodern
cult that they should maybe just not
take it.
But then I got um,
a real interesting email from a guy,
I won't tell you his name,
but who's a computer programmer.
And he put together an AI system to
parse apart postmodern,
the postmodern lexicon automatically.
And he set up a website now where
students can feed in course descriptions
of any sort and it will spit out whether
or not they're postmodern and he's,
we're developing.
So the point is to get the,
to get the program up to the point where
it can automatically distinguish between
postmodern and non postmodern content.
And then students will be able to cut
and paste a course description and,
and paste it into the analysis box on
this website along with the professor's
name and the course's name and the
discipline and the university.
And so we should be able to produce a
listing of every university in every
course that people are willing to
participate in analyzing across North
America and set up a list of courses and
professors and disciplines that should
be avoided.
And,
and so maybe we can start them out at
[inaudible]
source and that's what should happen.
So it has,
it has to be bottom up as far as I can
tell for this to come to an end.
And it should come to an end because the
postmodern neo Marxist doctrine is
nothing but a cult,
except that it's the sort of cult that
doesn't have enough economic sense to
run itself out of profit.
So not only is it a cult,
it's a failed cult,
and if it was so,
it's a cult that has to be subsidized by
the public purse in order to exist at
all.
So that's like you'll have some pretty
damn pathetic cult because normally if
you're a decent cult leader,
you can at least figure out a way to
pick the pockets of your,
of your victims in a manner that
enriches you.
So I can't even manage to get that
right,
which I think accounts for their
anticapitalist biased because they
haven't been able to transform their
radiological doctrine into some way of
making themselves spontaneously rich.
Although it certainly seems to have done
a great job of late ladling students
with observed levels of student loans in
the United States is exactly the point
in their life where they should be free
to make entrepreneurial decisions and
take some risks,
which is also something that I regard as
absolutely reprehensible.
So universities have figured out how to
conspire in some sense to pick the
future pockets of the students that
they're purporting to,
to educate.
And they're not educating them.
They're indoctrinating them,
they're not teaching them how to speak,
they're not teaching them how to debate.
They're not teaching them how to write.
They're not introducing them to the
classical wisdom of the western Judeo
Christian tradition.
And that's an absent.
That's absolutely appalling.
Cause that's what the bloody institution
was there for to begin with.
And that's what it's supposed to be.
Okay.
Yeah.
So what else do I have to tell you about
that?
Yeah.
Oh yes.
I just have one more thing.
I guess that one of the things that I'm
quite was quite curious about was,
um,
okay,
I'll tell you about two things.
One of the things I was quite curious
about is the postmodern say neo Marxists
insistence that the only true human
motivation is power.
Now I've been thinking about that in a
couple of ways.
I think that was actually Marxist
sleight of hand at the end of the 1960s
because the original Marxist
revolutionary doctrine was that Western
society,
let's say capitalist society.
But you can think about it more broadly.
A society in general,
it's basically best conceptualized as a
zero sum zero sum game fought to the
death between the oppressors and the
oppressed and be the proletariat and the
bourgeoisie let's say.
And you know,
as we as we know playing that game in
places like Soviet Union and mouse
charring,
it didn't work out so well for every one
sold.
There were seem to be a fundamental flaw
in the conceptualization.
Although people could always excuse that
by saying,
well that's not real communism,
which is the sort of statement that
should immediately get you punched in
the nose hard enough to knock you out
far as I'm concerned.
So because the statement like that
reveals only one thing,
and what it reveals is that if you had
been fortunate enough to be in the
position,
the position of Joseph's tell him that
you wouldn't have been quite the
murderous monster that he was because
your moral character is such that you
wouldn't have been swayed by access to
that kind of extreme power.
And if you're,
if you dare to make that claim,
then there's some things about yourself
and humanity that you should learn and
you should learn them rapidly before you
pose more of a danger to yourself then
and others then you already post.
So,
so then,
so part of it is the postmodernist
turned the Marxist emphasis on economics
into an emphasis on power in the 1970
[inaudible].
And I think they did that as a form of
sleight of hand because by the late
1960s and early 1970s it was obvious
even to people as intransigent as
someone as Saint John Paul Sartre,
which one who refused to denounce the
communist party until that late in the,
in that progression of the 20th century,
it became obvious even to people like
that,
that there was just no way that you
could maintain your intellectual and
moral credibility and remain a supporter
of standard communist doctrine.
And also it seemed to be the case that
strangely enough,
contrary to Marxists prediction,
that the working class in the West was
getting richer and richer than people
had ever got in history,
rather than being increasingly
downtrodden by the brute.
He'll of the,
of the,
of the corporate and capitalist elite.
So it was not a revolution that was
particularly easy to sell.
Part of the sleight of hand was,
oh,
it's not about economic power,
it's about oppression and oppressed and
oppressor on a broader sense.
And that's where we got the
transformation into identity politics,
which is just the Marxist oppressor,
oppressed doctrine.
Under a new guys and I think it's really
tremendously reprehensible for people
to,
to be conducting themselves
intellectually in a manner that insists
that the most important element of any
student or any person for that matter is
whatever racial,
gender and sex identity happens to be
flavor of the month.
And I think the problem with that
fundamentally is first of all that that
those categories systems are
extraordinarily loose and there
indefinitely multiply bubble,
you know,
because if you take any given
individual,
there's probably,
well it's the postmodern problem.
Ha Ha.
There we go.
It's the postmodern problem that there's
almost an infinite number of ways to
categories any given individual.
So how the hell you figure out which
group they belong to.
And that's actually a major problem.
Like if you're one eighth black,
what does that make you exactly?
Are you black?
Are you white?
Are you oppressed?
Are you oppressor?
Are you,
are you,
let's see,
one half is oppressed as someone who's a
quarter black.
Does it work out arithmetically that
way?
Hey,
I'm dead serious about this man.
If,
if we're going to play this sort of
game,
that's exactly the question that has to
be asked,
right,
and then how do you,
how do you multiply up you're oppressed
identities and then again,
who decides who gets to decide exactly
which identity you should manifest and
then how do we rank order those
identities and then how do we equate
between them and what measurement
techniques do we use to determine who's
who's oppressed and who isn't and how do
we assess equality and on what
dimensions are we going to assess
equality and who's going to enforce it
and who's going to make the decisions?
It's like,
oh,
well,
we'll figure that out as we go along.
It's like,
yeah,
we certainly will and the results won't
be pretty.
I can tell you that because,
because the problem is actually
unsolvable,
all it'll mean is that those,
those categories will be made at the
whim of the people who are making the
categories and since as we know,
the only thing they believe in power is
power.
That the only thing they believe in his
power is that you can be absolutely sure
that they will have absolutely no
hesitancy whatsoever to use power in the
seeking of their aims and I think the
other reason that all of the
postmodernist new Marxists ever do is
talk about power is because they want to
justify their use of power to get
exactly what they want when they want
it.
There's nothing but power.
It's like,
all right,
if there's nothing but power,
that means we're at more power and that
is,
that's the claim that you make.
Then you can justify the use of power
because there isn't anything else to
turn to.
There's no logic,
there's no dialogue,
there's no consensus,
there's no discussion between well
meaning people,
there's nothing but divisions between
power groups and identity groups and
hobbsy in state of war between all of
us.
Well,
when I look at people aiming at that,
they're not then my proclivity as a
psychoanalyst just to think that that's
exactly what they want and to divide us
off all by race and ethnicity and sexual
identity and sexual preference and
sexual expression and gender identity
and all of these multiplying forces of,
of group identities seems to be nothing
but an invitation to chaos.
And that's exactly what I see looming.
And it needs to come to a stop and it
needs to come to a stop as fast as
possible.
And one way of doing that is to stop the
universities from continuing to
indoctrinate young people who really,
at least two at the beginning,
don't know any better into play in these
absolutely insane.
And I would say bordering on murderous
intellectual games.
And so,
so then I'm going to set up this website
and maybe some other wasn't slight it.
And I'm going to do a series of videos
for young university students and for
high school students.
And I'm going to tell them that perhaps
they don't need to go to university to
be indoctrinated.
Perhaps they could go to university to
learn.
And if they want to know the difference
between an educator and someone who's
merely interested in indoctrination and
the production of the next generation of
pathetic wining radicals,
then they can use the,
then they can use the website to
distinguish between people who are
credible and people who aren't.
And maybe we can drop the damn
enrollment in those horrible courses by
75% over the next three years and just
stop it in its tracks.
So anyways,
that's a part of the plan.
And,
and,
and I think it's,
I think it's something that's actually
implementable.
These things can turn around fast and
one of the ways that they'll turn around
is that if people just stop taking the
courses.
And so what people need to do in order
to know that they should stop taking the
courses is to know that these is to know
what it is that these courses are aiming
at.
So that needs to be explained.
Then they need to know what language the
people who teach these courses are using
in order to fulfill those aims.
Then they need to know how to identify
the courses.
Then they need to know that it's in
their best interest.
Both I would say spiritually and
economically to avoid those courses and
those disciplines like the plague.
And then maybe we can get the
disciplines that have become entirely
corrupt and the ones that started that
way to put themselves back together
before they run themselves out of
existence completely.
And I might as well name a few of the
disciplines that I think are
particularly reprehensible to begin
with.
I'm obviously,
I'm painting this with a very broad
brush and I'm not making the claim that
every single person who engages in
activity within all of these disciplines
has been corrupted beyond comprehension
by the postmodernist neo Marxists.
But it's close enough.
First pass approximation.
So,
um,
as I said already,
women's studies and all the ethnic
studies in racial studies groups mad,
those things have to go in that faster
they go,
the better they should never be.
It would have been better had they never
been part of the university to begin
with.
As far as I can tell a sociology that's
corrupt,
anthropology,
that's corrupt English literature that's
corrupt.
Um,
maybe the worst offender or the
faculties of education.
And I would say,
I read the recent poll,
I read the recent policy documents have
the um,
elementary teachers,
Federation of Ontario,
and I can tell you,
you can go read it.
It's right on your website.
Is that their plan?
And they just say it,
I'm not making this up.
You don't need any inferences.
There's,
there's nothing implicit about it is to
reorganize the curriculums from
kindergarten to grade eight so that
children are taught to be social justice
warriors from the moment they step foot
in the public education system.
That's exactly what they're doing.
They're making that,
they're making this look.
I mean we have social justice tribunals
in Ontario.
Okay.
That's not subtle in case you didn't
notice to name them social justice
tribunals,
that's not subtle.
And so you see the same sort of language
in the ETF.
Oh,
documents is that social justice is the
right way to go.
The appropriate thing to do is to train
children to follow precisely that
pathway.
And the best way to do it is to get them
as young as possible.
It's like,
and that's the faculties of education
for you.
And they're not producing people who are
interested in educating children at all.
And they're doing,
they're taking the easy route and what
they're doing is training people who who
can memorize and then spew forth a one
dimensional view of humanity and then
have the gall,
the unmitigated gall to presume that
what they should be doing with children
is indoctrinating them into that
particular line of thinking from his
early an age as possible.
And so faculties of education,
they need to be fixed and they need to
be fixed fast.
And then,
and this is where I'll stop,
one of the most shocking things I
learned this year,
so I didn't really know this,
but I,
I didn't learn this till I went to
Queens University cause I went to Queens
University.
I was invited there by a group of law
students,
you know,
and I was their hope hypothetically to
debate bill see 16 and the students went
to all the law professors and asked them
if they would debate me and none of them
would.
And I thought,
well,
I thought,
yeah,
well that figures first of all,
that's what I thought because,
well,
but it,
but then I thought,
Geez,
that's pretty absurd because I'm a
psychology professor and you know,
law lawyers,
one thing lawyers are pretty good at is
arguing if they're good lawyers.
I mean that in a complementary manner.
I mean that's what you learned to do
when you're a lawyer,
you learn to speak,
you learn to formulate an argument and
you learn to forgive me,
formulate an argument on virtually any
set of principles because you know
you're acting as defense or you're
acting as prosecution and you need to be
flexible on your feet and put forward
the best possible argument given the
facts at hand.
And they couldn't find anybody to debate
me.
So Bruce Party,
who's a professor there had to act as
devil's advocate,
which he did quite nicely,
but I thought that was pretty,
pretty appalling to say the least,
that they were either so ideologically
rigid that they wouldn't confront me on,
on their bloody territory.
It's like if,
uh,
if the NFL,
if a law professor from Queens wanted to
come and debate me about psychology,
hey,
there'd be no problem with that because
that after all is my field of expertise
and the fact that a law professor
wouldn't come forward and debate me on a
legal matter.
I thought it was just,
I didn't even know what to think about
that.
But one of the things I did learn,
and I've really learned this more,
is that law has actually become corrupt
as well as a discipline.
And it's not so much,
I know a lot of lawyers and I've worked
with a lot,
but most of them have been more on the
corporate and business end of things.
And so,
but all the human rights law,
all the law that doesn't seem to be
attached in some sense to business
concerns has also become corrupt and
social justice oriented beyond belief.
And the students had queens were
complaining to me that they weren't
lending any law in their courses.
All they were learning with social
justice propaganda.
And so you bloody well better watch out
for that.
I can tell you because the people who
make your legislation or lawyers and
they're making plenty of legislation
that is not in your best interest.
And even worse than that,
perhaps it's not even in the best
interest of the people for whom the
legislation purports to protect because
the bloody legislation and the policies
are so incoherent and so badly written
like bill [inaudible].
Here's one of the things it did.
No one knows this and I can't believe
they haven't noticed.
You know,
the strongest argument that gay people
have had for the last 50 years for being
included in broader society and let's
say tolerated so to speak or welcomed
for that matter,
is that it was a biological phenomenon.
You know,
and I'd say the evidence for that isn't
overwhelming,
but it's,
it's certainly suggestive.
It's like bill see 16 is eradicated that
because it's predicated on the
presupposition that there's no
relationship,
that the relationship between biological
sex,
gender identity,
gender expression,
and sexual proclivity is independent.
They blew out the structure that enabled
them to make the argument for including
the written for pursuing the rights to
begin with.
And so if I was a good,
hateful,
right wing radical and feeling rather
anti in my orientation,
let's say,
I might say something like,
Oh,
I see.
It's just something you learned,
is it?
Well,
how bout you unlearn it?
And if it's just your whim,
well then why should I put up with it at
all?
And that's actually written into the
damned legislation now.
So,
so watch the lawyers because they're
being trained as social justice warriors
and they're producing incoherent bits of
legislation that are going to produce a
tremendous amount of problems as they
roll through the legal system.
So anyways,
in closing,
the closing is,
it's a war of ideas and it's an
educational problem.
And what we're going to try to do is to
educate students well enough.
Well,
they're making their course decisions so
that they can stop being indoctrinated
by people who should have known better
than to do that to begin with.
And so that's the plan for the next
couple of years,
and hopefully it will be effective.
So thank you.